so for the first time in more than a
year joe biden is making border security
his top priority not our southern border
which has become a playground for drug
smuggling cartels but the border of
russia and ukraine he cares so much
about russia's border aggression he sent
his two best people to europe there to
get things under control
secretary of state tony blinken who
managed to detonate kabul while
vacationing in the hamptons this
september
and vice president kamala harris who is
still on the hunt for the root causes of
her bad poll numbers
she didn't find them in munich this
weekend but she did tell americans
buckle up
the price of gas is about to get a whole
lot more expensive
when america stands for her principles
and all the things that we hold dear
it requires sometimes for for us to put
ourselves out there
in a way that maybe we will incur some
cost and in this
situation
that may relate to energy costs
so they waited about two months to trot
harris out in germany with a mask on to
say yeah this situation in ukraine
is going to make gas more expensive
we're going to feel a lot more pain at
the pump
all in exchange for america standing up
to its principles
and there's no sign that this is getting
any better since the buy administration
quietly halted
just a couple days ago new oil drilling
on federal lands
why would they do that if energy prices
are about to skyrocket because of
ukraine why would they do that
they're making their message clear
ukraine's problems
are worth more than your problems the
question is
can they handle two crises at once and
can they walk and chew gum at the same
time
we ought to babel that old that trade
expression walking chew gum at the same
time the president can walk and chew gum
at the same time we ought to be able to
walk and chew gum at the same time
can you joe
and
why ukraine why now
that was joe
chewing gum when he was going up the
stairs
if eastern europe's independence was so
critical to our principles maybe we
wouldn't have spent three decades of
foreign policy trying to expand nato
into former soviet territories remember
joe was on the front lines of that not
too long ago
for 40 years the united states loudly
proclaimed its solidarity with the
captive nations of central and eastern
europe
who were under the heel of the communist
oppressor
now that most of them have cast off
their shackles it's our responsibility
to live up to our pledges to readmit
them into the west through nato
so for decades biden and everybody's
pushed push push nato expansion nato
expansion russia says no no no that's a
threat and here we are in ukraine
this is where we are the dc swamp had
their history
of screwing over ukraine remember bill
clinton coerced ukraine to give up its
nukes back in the 90s
putin wouldn't have been invading now if
ukraine had nukes trust me
let's not forget the 2014 coup in
ukraine where barack and joe biden had a
little hand in replacing that
pro-russian elected president
now what so does dc even care about
what's really going on in ukraine like
they say they do doesn't seem like it
seems like this is just one big
distraction
for everybody in washington
maybe they'll make a quick dime over
this like they have been
place has been a piggy bank
for washington establishment types
they're just going to ignore all our
struggles here